zugeschaltet christian lindner guten
abend herr lindner ja tolle frau
würzburg thüringen ist das einzige
bundesland mit einem ministerpräsidenten
der linken sagen sie trotzdem bodo
ramelow der macht jetzt alles richtig
nein richtig ist und gut ist dass wir
eine diskussion führen ob und inwieweit
die hygiene und abstandsregeln noch mit
der rigorosität wie wir sie haben
fortgesetzt werden das ist richtig dass
es die debatte gibt bei der antwort
darauf bin ich noch unentschieden
ich glaube das ist mit sicherheit
regionen gibt wo es sehr empfehlenswert
ist weiter auf abstand zu gehen weiter
auch masken zu tragen generell dort wo
viel publikumsverkehr es wo menschen
also mit vielen fremden in kontakt
kommen empfiehlt sich das an anderen
stellen wird man schon lockern können
also regionalisierte zugang könnte
empfehlenswert seien aber das muss man
sehr sorgfältig auch mit den experten
mit biologen und epidemiologen
besprechen also ist thüringen jetzt ein
vorbild ja oder nein
was weiß ich noch nicht
erstens kenne ich noch nicht die
maßnahmen in thüringen und zweitens wage
ich noch nicht eine klare antwort auf
ihre frage wann soll es so machen wie in
thüringen das muss man sehr genau
besprechen und und diskutieren auch mit
den experten
es ist ja bereits viel gelockert worden
wir haben wieder gastronomie wir haben
wieder gesellschaftliches und
wirtschaftliches leben
ob und inwieweit man darüber hinaus
jetzt auch in dem ganz individuellen
bereich auf abstand und maske verzichten
soll
da meine ich müssen wir sorgfältig
diskutieren das ist keine diskussion
da geht es ja schließlich auch
menschenleben gesundheitsschutz wie wir
jetzt zu schnell abschließen sollten
also für mich verbietet sich da ein
rasches ja oder nein so in der
spontaneität eines wochenendes
sie hatten auf twitter herrn ramelow
jetzt erst mal gelobt für diese aktion
den tätern aber wieder gelöscht warum ja
ganz einfach weil ich glaube dass die
debatte länger gefühl
werden muss kommt etwas zweites hinzu
ich möchte die diskussion durchaus erst
mal unseren fachpolitikern überlassen
und ich selbst mich so äußeren damit die
fdp als partei festlegen wir haben ja
auch landesregierungen und deshalb sehr
aufmerksam von ihnen aber ihr habt noch
nach fünf minuten gesagt nein geht
debatte warten wir lieber einmal ab das
heißt wenn sie erstmal abwarten wollen
warum dann überhaupt der tweet ja ich
habe ihn ja korrigiert
sie sind also noch absolut
unentschlossen ob man jetzt bundesweit
lockerungen weiter fortführen sollte
oder erstmal abwarten sollte ich finde
es richtig und das habe ich ja übrigens
auch zum ausdruck gebracht also wenn sie
schon einen tweet zurückgezogen ist
zitieren dann wollen wir auch richtig
über die position sprechen
ich finde die debatte richtig und zwar
deshalb weil einschränkungen von
grundfreiheiten weil eingriffe in unsere
bürgerrechte immer diskutiert werden
müssen
daran muss immer die frage gerichtet
werden wie lange wie weit gibt es
mildere mittel kann man darauf
verzichten und deshalb ist diese
diskussion nötig die muss jeden tag
geführt werden welche einzelne
einschränkung unserer freiheit ist
eigentlich noch verhältnismäßig auch
welche andere kann man verzichten
die debatte muss geführt werden und
insofern habe ich gesagt ja wohl wenn
sich schon das ansprechen verwirrt dann
wird das auch klar hier noch mal sagen
wie auch zu beginn unseres gesprächs
jawohl es ist richtig die debatte zu
führen welches ergebnis sie hat das wird
man aber etwas länger miteinander
beraten müssen und ich ahne es wird
regional unterschiedliche antworten
darauf geben weil ja auch das
infektionsgeschehen ganz unterschiedlich
ist wir haben länder ohne neue infektion
also bundesländer in deutschland ohne
neue infektion und in den regionen gilt
anderes als an hotspots am ende egal auf
welcher seite diskussion mann ist muss
man sagen es war jetzt ein alleingang
von thüringen finden sie das überhaupt
in ordnung
ja da bin ich anderer meinung als auch
eine stimme die sie eben eingefangen
wir haben sehr große bundesländer wie
nordrhein-westfalen da gibt es regional
schon enorme unterschiede und deshalb
ist meine überzeugung schon länger wir
müssen regional mitunter bezogen auf
einzelne stadtteile oder gemeinden
maßnahmen treffen um infektionsherde zu
identifizieren und infektionskette zu
unterbrechen
aber das was in in coesfeld nötig ist
das muss nicht automatisch auch die
richtige antwort an der ganz anderen
ecke der republik in passau sein und
deshalb ist eine regionalisierte zugang
richtig bezogen auf ein bundesland
vielleicht auch mit sicherheit regional
richtig und andere länder werden sich
jetzt auch positionieren jeweils in
abhängigkeit von individuellen
infektionsgeschehen es ist ja auch
denkbar dass man modifiziert produkt
denken wir daran dass es möglich ist zum
beispiel eine masken pflicht weiter auch
zu beanspruchen das aber darüber hinaus
möglich wird dass man sich mit mehr als
zwei haushalten
treffen kann es jetzt auch eine regelung
man konnte ja sagen abstand gilt maske
gilt aber es dürfen auch mehr als zwei
haushalte zusammen kommt das passiert ja
sowieso vielfach in der praxis schon
jetzt an vielen stellen
und deshalb könnte das ein sinnvoller
weiterer schweizer denken sie dass der
druck jetzt auf die anderen dessen nein
wenn der chef es trotzdem erhöht ist ja
die debatte wird ihre wirkung nicht
verfehlen
in jeder region in jedem land wird man
jetzt die frage danach stellen ob und
inwieweit bestimmte regeln noch aufrecht
erhalten bleiben müssen
ob er sie aufrecht erhalten müssen oder
ob es modifikationen gibt die debatte
wird geführt
und da wird es auch unterschiedliche
antworten geben und unterstreichen
nochmal regional unterschiedlich
vorzugehen ist ja richtig wenn auch das
infektionsgeschehen sich stark
unterscheidet wir haben hotspots und wir
haben regionen ohne neuinfektionen und
in einer region ohne neuinfektionen muss
anderes gelten als dort wo es noch ein
starkes infektionsgeschehen gibt
beispielsweise habe ich einen guten
freund
er arbeitet mit seiner frau im home
office mit zwei kleinen kindern in
seinem landkreis gibt es keinerlei
neuinfektionen und wenn ich richtig aus
dem kopf war es überhaupt noch zwei
aktive infektionen niemand im
krankenhaus und er fragt sich warum
sollen bei uns die kitas erst im august
wieder öffnen
wir wollen jetzt dass die kinder wieder
mit gleichaltrigen spielen können wir
für euch jetzt auch wieder zu einem
normalisierten familien leben
zurückkehren können die oma müssen wir
nicht sofort besuchen die ist gefährdet
aber zumindestens wir wollen ein
bisschen mehr bewegungsfreiheit haben
wir wollen auch gerne mal wieder ins
büro
hey wir haben gerade schon heftige
prügel szenen aus augsburg gezeigt
zwischen der polizei und einigen
besuchern eines wirtshaus und der wird
ihn selber wir wollen die szenen jetzt
auch einmal noch mal zeigen
dort geht es darum um 22 uhr sollte
schluss sein aber die menschen wollten
das nicht und es gibt in deutschland ich
jetzt immer mehr größere gruppen die
sich wieder treffen und es eben nicht
einsehen und nicht auf die polizei oder
das ordnungsamt hören sondern auch
bewusst provozieren was denken sie ist
jetzt die beste umgangsweise mit diesen
problemen oder dieser situation polizei
wenn es dann immer wieder zu solchen
szenen kommt regeln werden eingehalten
man kann regeln politisch diskutieren
aber wenn es regeln gibt müssen sie
eingehalten werden und wie sie wissen
bin ich kein großer freund von
bürokratismus also von zu viel
regulierung an den stellen wo wir sie
nicht brauchen aber die regeln die es
gibt die müssen durchgesetzt werden und
da hat nur der staat nur unser
demokratischer rechtsstaat das
gewaltmonopol und da kann es keine keine
subversion geben von menschen egal
weiter zusammen feiern wollen
da kann es auch keine zusammenrottungen
und keine tumult situationen geben um zu
versuchen die staatsmacht
zurückzudrängen sondern da muss der
staat sein gewaltmonopol durchsetzen
auch mit den dafür erforderlichen
maßnahmen vielen dank christian lindner
für dieses interview nennt schönen abend
ihnen
dankeschön